voting is underway in Thailand's general
election seen as a potential turning
point for the country more than 50
million ties are electing 500 members in
the lower house the military-backed
Prime Minister prayer chanocha is
running for re-election eight years
after coming into power in a 2014 coup
opinion polls are indicating major gains
for the opposition at the expense of the
governing parties in a likely test for
the pro-military establishment let's go
to Tony Chang who joins us now live from
Bangkok Tony so what have been the main
issues in the run-up to this election
I think the economy is dominating the
minds of Voters here but I think also
it's a choice for them to either choose
between the status quo we've seen
military-backed parties ruling this
country since the coup in 2014 or to
make a choice and I think we've seen
from the polls and the build up to the
election that many people do want change
they are not particularly happy with the
state of the economy they weren't very
happy with the way the coronavirus
pandemic was handled and they wanted
more Progressive more forward-thinking
government there are lots of people
turning out here where we are in the
north of Bangkok we understand that's
the case all around the country today
the election commission says as many as
85 percent of Voters could turn out
they've got a large number of people to
choose from 70 parties on the ballot
paper but it is their basic Stark choice
between status quo and change I think a
lot of Voters also recognize that the
vote they cast today won't be the end of
this matter this is just the start of
the process the election commission
Mission which has favored the
military-backed governments in the past
is already investigating the two main
parties of opposition also anyone who
wins this election has to get over the
military-backed Senate which is 250
votes and it looks like at the moment as
if no one will get the overall majority
they need of 376 votes I think also
there's a hope here that from voters
that if they come out in the lodge in
very large numbers and if their choices
is very clear then there won't be the
option for too many people to interfere
with the result okay thank you for that
Tony Chang there for us in Bangkok let's
get more on this we can speak to
panchada City wanabud who's an associate
professor of social sciences at majidol
University she joins us in Bangkok thank
you for your time Thai politics has as
we've been hearing there been dominated
by the military and the monarchy for
decades is there a public appetite for
change this time around
well good morning from Bangkok yeah this
time you know a lot of water especially
the Young Generation won't change
because of the kind of slow down and
some of the things that the government
cannot really handle it but this time
that you know there's a large numbers of
people will go out to vote uh for the
pre-elections 90 percent of water
turnouts in Thailand last week and this
time we are expecting about 80 percent
of voter turnouts and this time you know
um we can see that a high potential for
the opposition parties
um led by you know the protaxing the
former government of Thailand so-called
Thai party we will win the great test
number succeed but again you know um
last election third time also won the
election but they could not really form
the government to form the government
maybe another story good time maybe has
a you know very very problem you know to
form the government after this election
because you know as mentioned earlier
it's really difficult for Thai to be in
376 in order to nominate the prime
Minister and to form the coalition
government
and you're talking about opposition
parties I mean there's poor Thai which
is the popular Pro Reform Party but this
time it's also up against a newer
anti-military party the move forward
party which is very popular with the
younger generation I believe tell us a
bit more about them and how you expect
them to do
yeah well uh in this election I'm
expecting you know the upload time will
be number one move forward BB number two
but I think it's a bit really difficult
for blood Thai and move forward to form
coalition government together because
move forward party proposed the 112
article which basically is about the you
know revisions or the reform of the
early Majesty law which is I don't think
that but I would love to join this party
in order to form the college's
government if they want the government
you know to be in the long term to stay
in four years term I think they need to
fight um after a political party that
you know have the policy go along with
it and move forward party this time you
know we have a lot of young voters about
14 million and a lot of first-time
Waters I think most of them are really
Keen to work for the move forward party
as you can see said you know a lot of
number of people especially the Young
Generation they travel back home in
other provinces just to vote this is the
really surprising circumstance Sunset
intellectual in Thailand we don't really
see a large numbers of people go out of
Bangkok and trying to vote or trying to
cast that vote in the pre-elections day
yeah that's interesting
um and and tell us a bit more about why
uh even if one of these pro-reform
anti-military party wins they won't be
able to necessarily be able to form a
government I mean what is the reason for
that and what is it going to take to
change that
well in the um you know for the
pro-democratic party it's a bit
difficult for them because you know in
order to form the coalition government
and to to nominate the Prime Minister
the political party have to get at least
half of the whole house both of the
upper and lower half which is about 376
and so far you know if you can uh from
the poll that have report put high or
protaxin party they can gain about 170
or 200 C which is difficult to to form
you know the coalition government or if
you have the you know minority
government is really difficult for putai
to pass any laws after they're elected
so I think this is a difficult time for
Apple Thai that's why they have to fight
other political parties and I think that
they will form you know they have a high
potential for blood type party to form
the coalition government with one or two
from the political party from the
conservative side I believe that it's
possible you know to forget how to form
the coalition government with the
pro-military government
and some other conservative side party
in order to maintain you know 376 or at
least 250 in order to pass a law when
they have a coalition government being
set really interesting to get your
inside panchada City wonderboard
associate professors social sciences at
mahido University speaking to us there
from Bangkok thank you